[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonjour à tous donc je m'appelle
christophe mazola je suis expert en
cybersécurité et je suis le consultant
fondateur du site aussi starter tonnes
alors la cyber sécurité est un domaine
vraiment intéressant chaque jour je
découvre qu'en fait je ne sais rien
cette phrase je vous la laisse ses
cadeaux c'est un constat que nous sommes
faits au cours de ces dernières années
et pour laquelle
ga
je me rends compte que la cybersécurité
est un monde à part entière qui mérite
d'être découvrir et qui est un monde à
découvrir et on va essayer de vous
ouvrir les portes de ce monde et donc
dans la cybersécurité
la première question que je me suis
posée sur ce raid qui est le thème
exploite au monde c'est de quel monde on
parle est ce qu'on parle du réel ou du
numérique de fait de notre de notre
spécialisation est donc la première
question qui nous est venue de quelle
identité disposons-nous dans la vie la
première c'est l'identité réelle je
m'appelle christophe maes voilà et pour
moi
je
souhaite par l'identité li na li qui est
l'ensemble des tribus que vous laissez
sur internet vous connectez vous quand
vous inscrivez un site internet
le consultant on le connaît sur cette
identité là et je les crée justement
pour ne pas avoir d'impact dans
et justement cette question nous soulève
la nounou soulève le fait de s qu'un
impact dans la une action dans la dans
le numérique a un impact dans la vie
réelle et la réponse est évidemment oui
ça peut être quelque chose de négatif
malheureusement ça peut être des
informations que l'on voit qu'ils
peuvent heurter la sensibilité des
personnes mais également des campagnes
de cyber harcèlement pour le cyber
harcèlement il ya un outil qui est
formidable qui était mis en place par le
gouvernement qui est la ligne verte 30
18 et concernant les informations
délictuelle je sais que tu es un
plateforme que j'aime profondément
seulement pour l'identité numérique et
pour vous protéger en cas de menace si
berne que toujours comment dire vous
connecter sur faro ce qui est ainsi du
gouvernement et qui vous permet
justement de dénoncer toute conduite
électoral qui pourrait mettre à mal
notre identité numérique et
éventuellement à paris
je vois qu'un bébé est d'accord avec
nous notre domaine donc c'est la
cybersécurité et ce n'est pas seulement
la manière dont
appelle les bad guys les acteurs
agissent au quotidien mais c'est comment
nous ce qu'on appelle les good guys who
pour quelqu'un comme le consultant les
personnes un peu plus neutre à agissent
au quotidien et sont dépendants de ces
outils numériques car au final nous
avons ces dernières années accepter
d'utiliser des outils numériques et de
leur donner une certain nombre
d'informations sans pour autant armer la
population de 2 des dangers de
l'utilisation de ces outils à une époque
où internet n'est pas encore développé
protéger son identité était assez facile
aujourd'hui dans un monde dont on est
dans une connexion permanente ce risque
qui était un niveau acceptable par le
passé ne l'est malheureusement plus du
tout et devient très compliqué et c'est
véritablement cette notion de risque
acceptable qui est le plus important
dans notre métier est un plat on va
freiner le slide est effectivement la
cybersécurité c'est la sphère de tous
absolument tous dans le cadre justement
de vos vies personnelles tout comme
d'origine professionnelle on doit faire
attention à tout ce qui concerne le
domaine cyber je suppose que la plupart
d'entre vous au sol ils reçoivent
souvent des campagnes
des préventions
le travail exactement qui vous pousse
justement à contrôler qui sont les
expéditeurs des notes que vous recevez
on vous demande de faire attention sur
les liens sur lesquels vous cliquez des
informations que vous laissez sur
internet de faire absolument attention à
tout et effectivement la cyber sécurité
c'est la sphère de tout c'est pas le but
non plus de se dédouaner mais on peut le
voir également que des actions dans le
numérique qui concerne du hacking a des
répercussions dans la vie de tous les
jours on peut le voir ça fait la une des
journaux à l'heure où nous enregistrons
cette vidéo on a appris cet après midi
que le ministère de la justice en france
s'est fait pirater il ya quelques jours
c'est une prison qui s'est fait qui
s'est fait pirater le réseau numérique a
été complètement mise à mal et un impact
dans le réel a été que les prisonniers
ont dû rester isolé à l'isolément dans
leur cellule pendant près d'une semaine
car leurs caméras de surveillance ne
fonctionnait absolument plus et un peu
plus loin dans le temps c'était l'été
dernier vous avez peut-être entendu
parler delà de la sphère colonial
pipeline c'est un prestataire qui
distribue du pétrole pour les stations
essence et les aéroports aux états unis
un type data qui s'appelle enfin avec un
logiciel malveillant qui est le rang
somewhere ou un rang son logiciel pour
la version francophone
a malheureusement impacter la
distribution de pétrole sur toute la
côte est des états unis et des personnes
qui n'avaient pas internet était
malheureusement impacté par une attaque
qui étaient bien fondées dans le
numérique
et donc la question qui vient à l'heure
actuelle c'est comment se protéger du
numérique dans le monde réel
on comme je le disais précédemment en
sécurisant leurs données en évitant de
trop en dire je sais que ça peut
paraître un peu étrange parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans l'ère dû
paraître où tout le monde se pose
constamment que ce soit sur facebook
l'instant grave du monde post des
informations qui peuvent paraître
anodine mais qui peuvent permettre à
certaines personnes qui sont
malveillantes et accéder à tous que vous
les cards et cachet typiquement
je sais pas vous poster une photo de
votre chien avec son nom c'est je trouve
que le nom du chien et le mot de passe
de votre boîte mail batman que les
renseigner sur votre linkedin on accède
à votre boîte mail on vole votre
identité et ça peut paraître anodin
également un vol d'identité en ligne
hongren identité ording d'avoir des
formes en papier dans le réel exactement
là là votre adresse mail est la porte la
plus vulnérable vers votre identité et
il faut la protéger comme en protège un
coffre fort et une analogie que j'aime
beaucoup qui est celle de la clé passe
partout il est est ce que vous assumerez
de par exemple utiliser la même clé pour
tous les biens qui sont les plus
importants dans votre vie voire pire en
utilisant un mot de passe qui est on va
dire très faible ou qui peut être
réutilisé sur d'autres sites est-ce que
vous accepterez de donner cette clé à
des inconnus ou à des hackers a disposé
à libre disposition
c'est comme ça qu'il faut voir les
choses ce n'est pas il faut vraiment
sortir du spectre du numérique pour se
rendre compte que des ce que le
comportement que vous même que vous
n'adoptez pas dans ma vie réelle
malheureusement vous l'adoptez dans le
numérique mais quand on parle de se
protéger l'eau si nécessaire de savoir
de qui on doit se protéger et pour ça il
ya six types de
de hackers et on va commencer par le
premier je pense que vous connaissez
bien cette image c'est un peu le cliché
du hacker comme on peut le voir dans les
séries télévisées ou dans l'est dans les
films au cinéma personnellement je sais
pas toi peut-être un peu mauvais exemple
du coup tu es cochet
mais en tout cas je connais très peu de
gens qui derrière leurs ordinateurs ont
une capuche sur la tête je sais pas vous
mais moi ce n'est pas mon cas et donc ce
titre de ce type de l'acteur on appelle
ça des loups solitaires ils sont
généralement pas intéressé par les par
l'aspect financier mais uniquement par
le challenge avec tu intellectuelle donc
à titre personnel ce n'est pas forcément
ce type de hackers comme zale a
rencontré dans la vie de tous les jours
vous allez peut-être connaître la
deuxième image il s'agit du groupe
anonymus qui est un des groupes
d'activistes les plus connus à travers
le monde et quand je parle d' activiste
c'est le mot valise entre hackers et
activiste ces gens là ne sont pas ne
sont pas à la recherche de de gains
financiers ils sont là uniquement pour
détruire la réputation de leurs victimes
et là maintenant on va passer ceux qui
cherchent l'argent et l'argent facile
une fois de plus ça va être très cliché
mais je connais pas des hackers qui sont
comme ça derrière leur smartphone ou
leur ordinateur mais c'est ce qu'on
appelle des petites frappes des bandits
de grands chemins qui vont chercher
l'aspect financier le plus rapidement
possible et si vous avez un minimum de
protection ils vont se dire ok on passe
à autre chose le rapport de travail et
de rentabilité n'est pas et n'est pas
intéressant il a on va passer dans un
domaine que tu aimes bien les
businessmans du acquis
que les groupes
à mettre en place dès les outils de
service qui tire vite pour prendre des
services sur internet le groupe qui a
aujourd'hui piraté le bilan la justice
se réclame de de ce genre de groupe
exactement extorquer des cibles qu'elle
soit
surtout gouvernementales et des
entreprises il faut savoir que
maintenant la plupart de ces groupes de
hackers sont deux sont de vrais business
travaille avec des entreprises qui des
façades d'entreprises qui sont bien
ancrés dans le réel et qui fournissent
donc des services de hacking à payable à
la prestation et on va continuer et on
va encore partir sur un cliché c'est le
cliché de la mafia on connaît tous la
mafia italienne avec les costumes les
chapeaux et bien en fait la mafia
traditionnel est également présente sur
les sur internet grâce effectivement à
l'appât du gain financier conséquent
qu'ils peuvent en tirer de par leurs
activités et enfin la dernière qui en à
titre personnel je pense aucune chance
que ça puisse arriver non ce sont ce
qu'on appelle les nations state warriors
se sont littéralement une armée de
cybercriminels et de cyber guerriers qui
sont à la disposition des différents
gouvernements avec en tête bien
évidemment la chine la russie et les
etats-unis mais quasiment tous les pays
ont ce type de hackers à leur
disposition
mais je pense que toi te connaissant tu
as d'autres
à personne en ligne de mire
moi personnellement non comment plus tôt
tu es plutôt une méfiance envers tout le
monde voilà fait disons que
la cybersécurité pour moi c'est le fait
de nous méfier d'un peu tout le monde
parce que aujourd'hui on a pas mal à se
faire des amis sur internet mais je
considère pas disons d'internet comme
des amis ça peut paraître un peu bizarre
de dire ça comme ça mais
pourtant peut être qu'aujourd'hui
pourtant on s'est rencontré sur internet
mais une personne qui est aujourd'hui
est considéré aujourd'hui comme un ami
peut devenir demain un ennemi et j'ai
servi à des renseignements qu'on lui a
données pour nous causer du tort sur
internet d'où le fait que tu s'amasser
masquer ce soir absolument est donc
maintenant qu'on sait de qui on doit se
protéger on va prendre un exemple on
vous rassure c'est un slide qui est bien
dans la présentation c'est normal c'est
pas mon courrier personnel donc ici nous
avons eu un courrier de la banque et
assurance carrefour vous avez très
certainement dû recevoir des mails on va
dire similaires c'est typiquement ce
qu'on appelle une campagne de phishing
et pour le cam français hameçonnage on
est en france on va parler français est
donc cet email je sais pas si vous avez
l'habitude de recevoir et quel est votre
comportement à que vous adoptez lorsque
vous recevez ce type gmail mais il est
très important de prêter attention à
chaque détail dans ce type 2
de communication ça peut paraître très
bas taux affichés comme ça mais je vous
garantis en fin de journée quand vous
êtes fatigué vous avez passé une journée
au téléphone derrière un écran
d'ordinateur
il est très facilement
ça arrive très facilement que vous
puissiez cliquer sur un lien et remplir
toutes les informations sans que vous
vous rendez compte et donc quand vous
avez ce type de mail en face de vous il
y a plusieurs informations à
très rapide que vous pouvez récupérer
qui vont qui vous font dire que non cet
email n'est pas légitime est-ce que tu
as quelques exemples à donner sur cet
e-mail par exemple les fautes
d'orthographe
la disposition le logo qui n'est pas
conforme il ya là l'adresse mail
également je fais également qui n'est
pas conforme
vous recommande également lorsque vous
recevez ce lendemain de chercher
vainement de la personne sur internet
souvent ce sont des personnes qui sont
totalement inventés et si vous n'avez
pas de compte bancaire assurance chez
carrefour d'avertir la personne si la
personne qui existent car justement
c'est via des campagnes de ce qu'on
appelle de choc rating ou en recense les
noms des personnes qui gagnent entre
autres
vous un recensement des personnes qui
travaillent dans une entreprise que l'on
peut justement très ce genre de mail à
prendre le nom de
véronique routier et en rires et en fait
quand vous exactement en fait quand vous
faites les recherches sur madame
routiers vous vous rendez compte que
dont elle ne travaille absolument pas
chez carrefour mais de deux il ya
énormément de sites qui ressent cette
arnaque et il a également plusieurs
arnaques à son nom et pas seulement du
côté de carrefour mais il ya aussi le
fait que cet e-mail n'est pas percé
personnalisée c'est à dire que si c'est
votre banque elle nous appelle pas cher
cliente chers clients elle vous appelle
par votre nom et votre prénom est
généralement qu'une carte est bloqué
vous avez un coup de fil du banquier
et donc par la suite il y à un autre
vecteur qui est très important c'est la
gestion des mots de passe je vous
rassure je donne beaucoup de conférences
en entreprise et de mon expérience
personnelle et mot de passe et je pense
que c'est également votre cas dans
l'assistance et bien malheureusement à
l'heure actuelle on doit toujours s'y
faire et il y a un minimum de
deux choses à savoir sur les mots de
passe la première séquence est possible
quatorze caractères minimum
souvenez-vous plus c'est long plus c'est
bon malheureusement ça s'applique aussi
pour les mots de passe
il a également moins trois types de
caractères il ya quatre types de
caractères différents entre les
majuscules et minuscules les chiffres et
les caractères spéciaux il en faut au
moins trois sur quatre pourquoi ces deux
actions car au plus le mot de passe sera
long et complexe au plus ce sera
difficile à pirater
troisième point c'est ne jamais
réutilisé son mot de passe comme
j'expliquais tout à l'heure c'est comme
donner un une clé passe partout pour
toutes vos serrures
quatrième point un exemple avec tedx on
se sécurise 13 points d'interrogation ça
peut paraître très anodins comme ça mais
avec un mot de passe de ce type vous est
entièrement sécurisé ne l'utilisé pas
celui ci
mais au moins vous avez un exemple et
enfin les deux derniers points activer
la double authentification quand cela
est possible et on va éviter
l'authentification biométrique donc avec
votre empreinte digitale ou avec votre
façon on en reparlera d'ici la fin de ce
speech et à la fin également utiliser un
gestionnaire de mots de passe sécurisés
est-ce qu'on a tous dit
oui et donc mais juste un petit les
meules par rapport à ce gestionnaire de
mots de passe
ce n'est pas forcément nécessaire
d'avoir un logiciel sur votre ordinateur
si par exemple vous noté et je sais que
ça peut paraître confus mais par exemple
si vous prenez un cahier un stylo govou
noter chacun de vos mots de passe et que
ce cahier est enregistrée temps fermée
dans un coffre à double tour ou dans
votre secrétaire là on arrive à un
niveau de risque acceptable une fois de
plus parce que personne n'aura xas
secrétaire à part vous ça sera toujours
plus efficace qu'un fichier excel
conscience et conséquence c'est
justement on peut le but de cette de ce
tête c'est que les gens n'ont pas
conscience des conséquences qui peut
avoir derrière derrière les traces qu'on
laisse en termes de haut sur internet en
termes de cybersécurité j'ai une
analogie que j'aime bien il faut savoir
être préparés c'est l'analogie de la
coupure de courant vous avez tous vécu
une coupure de courant je présume au
moins une fois dans votre vie et être
préparés c'est être le voisin qui va
avoir des bougies et des lampes torches
et lui est pas le voisin qui va les
taper chez son voisin de palier pour
demander des bougies et des lampes
torches
et là on va continuer un peu plus voilà
sûr on parlait justement des droits que
vous donnez à des applications à des
sites internet comme facebook ou twitter
et notre cher ami qui est spécialiste
dans ce domaine va pouvoir en parler
ici on a une application smartphone qui
vient ce qu'ils vendent android qui
permet de voir les les permissions que
vous donnez à une application et tous
ces applications vous de vous installez
vous donner des droits dessus et si on
regarde la liste qu'est ce qui te choque
dans cette liste que l'application
demande le droit à l'accès aux contacts
pas de caméra alors que entre autres
caméras demande également davodeau
modifier l'esthétique de votre de votre
téléphone et tout ça on parle quand même
d'une application qui simplement
modifier l'aspect de
de la lumière de votre flash et pourtant
plein de personnes l'ont installé ses
seins
un exemple bien connu beaucoup de
personnes de l'installer et pourtant à
vous donner la droite d'accéder à
l'inquiéter de votre
de votre smartphone
et donc comment évoluer évoluer dans le
bon sens c'est-à-dire évoluer et faire
de vous des professionnels de la
cybersécurité
car vous pouvez le devenir sans pour
autant être des spécialistes de la
cybersécurité et je vous invite ce soir
à
à faire la liste chez vous de toutes les
applications que vous utilisez et tous
les droits que vous donnez à ses
applications ça peut être très
intéressant de ce que vous allez trouver
et là je vais laisser la parole à un de
mes amis on parlait de traces qu'on
laisse sur internet il ya un exemple
très connu et je vais voulais et je vais
le laisser rentrer dans les détails
absolument c'était justement dans ce qui
était justement dans le cadre où une
personne famille et à faire des cyber
harcèlement et pensé qu'il était
totalement inconnu un jour il s'est mis
a posté sur son compte instagram des
photos de lui donc cette photo mais
qu'il a oublié c'est qu'il avait des
mines de soleil et que j'ai zoomé sur
ciné de soleil que des siennes capture
via les renseignements qu'il donnait
dans ce post précédent du corps utilité
dans une ville spécifique dans un pays
spécifique j'ai pu retrouver
l'emplacement exact
et on arrive là dessus sur l'emplacement
exact sur l'emplacement exact où il se
baladait d'hôtel en hôtel ou pensant
qu'il était totalement downing qui se
trouvait à resserrer rapidement les gens
donc les autorités auront été merci
juste après ça
merci à vous c'était fini
[Applaudissements]